لانه في السنوات الاخيره مع كل التطور
العلمي والطبي لم يعد الاصابه بالسرطان
حكما
بالاعدام لان هناك علاجات جديده تم الكشف
عنها في مؤتمر الاورام الامريكيه السنوي
الذي اختتم هذا الاسبوع
طورت عقارا جديدا للمصابين تحديدا بنوع من
سرطان الرئه معروف باسم غير صغير الخلايا
نتائج التجارب السريريه وجدت ان الاقراص
التي تم تناولها بالفم قلصت خطر الوفاه
بنسبه 51%
على جانب اخر شركه موديلنا انتجت بالتعاون
مع شركه
لقاحا جديدا ضد سرطان الجلد
طبعا لقاحات ام ار ان اي التي سمعنا عنها
مع جائحه كورونا ذات تذكرون نجحت في تقليل
خطر انتشار النوع الاكثر فتكا من سرطان
الجلد بنسبه
65% المزيد دائما من التفاصيل حول عمل هذه
اللقاحات والعقاقير المطوره مع لميس يا
لميس يا لميس يا لميس
اللقاحات لعلاج السرطان هو حلم يطارده
العلماء لعقود من الزمن قريبا قد يصبح
حقيقه ولقاحات يمكن انتاجها في اقل من
ثمانيه اسابيع
يعمل على تحفيز الجهاز المناعي على مهاجمه
نوع معين من الخلايا السرطانيه في اورام
المريض مع ترك الانسجه السليمه دون
مهاجمتها التقنيه الحديثه هي نفس الفكره
التي استخدمتها بعض الشركات في انتاج
لقاحات كوفيد وتستخدم مفهوم الطب الشخصي
بمعنى ان كل مريض يعالج وفق جناته بخلاف
نهج العلاج الموحد كالعلاج الكيماوي تؤخذ
عينه من ورم المريض ويتم تحديد الطفرات
غير الموجوده في الخلايا السليمه وبمساعده
الذكاء الاصطناعي يتم تصنيع لقاحات تستهدف
تلك الطفرات المسؤوله عن نمو السرطان اما
الاقراص التي يتم تناولها بالفم فتعمل على
وقف نشاط انزيم مسؤول عن تطور بعض انواع
السرطانات التي يصعب علاجها وبحسب اسرتك
تم استخدام الدواء من قبل ما يقرب من 700
الف مريض في جميع انحاء العالم
[موسيقى]
في الاستوديو تم الينا اختصاصيه علاج
الاورام الدكتوره ريهام عمر دكتوره صباح
الخير اهلا وسهلا
عليكم
صباح الامل والتفاؤل هل هذا الاكتشاف وهذه
اللقاحات تعطينا او العقاقير تعطينا املا
جديدا بان مرضى السرطان لن يعانون من
مستقبلا من طول فتره العلاج ومن كثافه
اكيد
هو حاليا في تطور هائل في علاج الاورام كل
يوم في دواء جديد وما بقاش بس العلاج
الكيماوي اللي كان مخيف للمرضى بسبب
اعراضه الجانبيه بقى في العلاج المناعي
وعلاجات موجهه كتير ودي ادت امل كبير يعني
حتى في حالات انتشار الاورام في الجسم
بيبقى فيه علاجات والمريض بيعيش في وضع
كويس وبيقدر يعيش ويمارس حياته الطبيعيه
وبقى في امل كبير ما بقتش دي نهايه العالم
يعني كل واحد بيسمع ان انا
موضوع اللقاحات اللي بتعتمد تقنيه
لا علاج سرطانات معينه هي جزء من علاج
معاني علاج مناعي
انا عندي شويه خبره في هذا الموضوع لانه
والدتي السنه اللي فاتت اصيبت
بالسرطان الرئه واخذت هذا العلاج تحديدا
مع علاجات وجراحه اخرى حابه اسال عن
الاعراض الجانبيه لانه هي يعني مع انه
العلاج كان ناجح الا انه هي صابها بعض
الاعراض الجانبيه اللي للاسف يعني متعبتها
لغايه الان شو هي الاعراض الجانبيه اللي
ممكن يتعرض لها المريض السرطان
الاعراض الجانبيه بتعتمد على ايه نوع
السرطان ده اولا ثانيا ايه بروتوكول
العلاج لان في بروتوكولات جديد كتير منها
العلاج المناعي زي ما انت قلتي في
العلاجات الموجهه كل علاج منهم له اعراض
جانبيه بس طبعا هي بقت اقل كتير من العلاج
الكيماوي
العلاج المناعي اعراضه الجانبيه اكتر حاجه
ان هو هو اساس شغله ان هو العلاج المناعي
بيخلي المناعه تبقى اقوى وتقاوم الورم
فيبدا التخلص منه وتتعرف عليه اصلا
فبيبدا يظهرها ويبدا المناعه نفسها تبقى
اقوى وتقضي على خلايا الاورام ففي نفس
الوقت بيحصل زي اوتو يعني زي بعض برده
الامراض زي الامراض المناعيه يعني انه بعض
اجسام مضاده تبدا تهاجم الجسم فهي هذه
الاعراض
هجمت الغدد بالظبط يا اما في الرئه يا اما
القول
[موسيقى]
العلاج احنا تعوقتنا ولكن كنت حابه اسالك
سؤال صغير جدا هل هو متاح لاي مريض عنده
هذا النوع من السرطان اللي هيل او غير
الخلايا الصغيره
في العلاج احنا بنتكلم على الباكسين مع
الامينوثيرابي ده في حالات الميلانوما او
الورم الميلاني اللي هو بيسيب الجلد
الشروط بتاعته انه الورم يكون السوء تماما
وبعد كده بندي العلاجين دول عشان نقلل
نسبه ارتجاع الورم بس ده حاليا بس
الدراسات هتدخل في اورام تانيه وان شاء
الله
نتمنى ان شاء الله هذه مسحه الامل وهذا
التفاؤل دائما تكون موجوده وخاصه لمرضى
السرطان واهلهم اللي اللي بالتاكيد يعامون
ربما اختصاصيه علاج الاورام الدكتوره
ريهام عمر شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقص ص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات